but what's up believe nation it's seven
how are we doing it is 11 o'clock East
Coast time it's time for Miami with you
guys I have committed to do this with
you guys every Thursday as much as
possible either just me and you doing an
AMA or if I have a guest on to answer
some questions
I see we already got some people in the
live chat thank you guys for joining I'm
excited I had a really late night last
night I was up till 2:30 plus I had a
crazy day yesterday we had a filming day
I invited some people who are on my
Facebook page to come in and join and
somebody travels from Detroit five hours
to get to my studio in Toronto got a
passport just for the occasion and so it
was a lot of fun be able to meet people
it's always great like I love me with
you guys here this is part of it and
it's always awesome be able to see the
faces so as a result of the crazy day my
brain is going wild and I didn't sleep
so well but I have a full day of
interview starting with this I'm
bringing you my energy and I want to
answer your questions so in the live
chat game your questions and let's do it
for however long we do it we'll see
between 30 and 60 minutes at sea first
stop Mitchell Smith Mitchell's I think
Mitchell's been the first one in on
these live a Emmys for a good a good
chunk of them so thank you thank you
Mitchell Smith one are you reading any
books lately if so what I am I'm I'm
slowly working my way through books I'm
not reading at the pace that I would
like to but I'm slowly making my way the
one I'm reading right now is habits
habits it's got this yellow cover and a
spin wheel on it basically looking at
how you build successful habits
interesting I'm still you know trying to
figure out how to best apply it to what
I'm doing but that's what I'm reading
right now but it'll probably be a while
I'm reading like five pages a day or
something it's super light I mean I read
my own book this one every morning what
payday and the other one at night so
that's what I'm reading what do you guys
were reading leaving in the chat maybe I
should pick up a different book Chris
Young
what's up Evan early again what are your
top five rules of success taking right
now from your mind top five all right I
believe be consistent don't listen to
the little man
follow your passion only got one more
and they got one more gotta make a can't
embrace failure don't be so afraid it's
kind of the same thing those are my five
next what do we got oh guys if you if
you tagged me it's a lot easier for me
to to see the questions
oh it says I've been I've been
disconnected from the chat what happened
are you guys seen the chat let me
refresh I'm gonna refresh my chat there
we go
shake music when I know so sorry guys I
missed a whole bunch of the chat my chat
disconnected so put it back in there if
you have a question tag me shake music
when do I know if the time is right to
drop my job the fact that you're asking
this question might mean that it's time
to drop your job but you drop your job
when you're not learning anymore
the point of having a job is to learn
yes you're making money but the point of
having a job is to learn and so if your
ambitions are to be an entrepreneur at
some point then you want to have a job
where you're gonna learn the skills you
need to be a successful entrepreneur and
so my favorite thing to do is if you
want to get into a business go work for
somebody who has built a business not a
giant business but ten employees or less
go work for them and just get exposure
to the industry and see if you like it
see if you want to be in that industry
build some contacts connections learn
how the how the industry works you're
gonna make mistakes and get paid to do
it that's the best thing so you're not
you're not losing money you're not
making mistakes and it's at your cost
somebody's teaching you how to do it and
so as an example you know I never really
had an official job on a
career path but when I sold my business
I was super curious about venture
capital I never had to raise venture
capital for my company but I was always
curious about how that worked how do you
raise angel Capital Heidi raised venture
capital I just didn't know about it and
so I kind of wandered around and did a
whole bunch of different ideas after I
sold my business and one of the ones
that I that I stuck with for almost two
years was a venture capital firm here in
my city Toronto and city and I wasn't an
employee with them but I I worked with
them and I learned unto them and there
were four main owners or are in their
sixties or seventies and they gave me a
lot of wisdom on how the venture capital
industry worked and I did that while I
figured out what else I wanted to do and
it ended up not being my career path I
well I do actually do some investing
into businesses so I guess that works
out but more from the angel side instead
of building businesses to then go where
is venture capital and go IPO so I
didn't want to be that financial broker
but I learned about the industry and so
I think that is what is really important
if you're not learning at your job
anymore that's when you need to leave if
you're not learning and making yourself
better and giving you the skills to
become an entrepreneur and eventually
fulfill the thing that you want to do
that's when you leave go find a
different job there's lots of jobs that
are open there's jobs in every industry
and if you show hustle and heart and
passion energy you can you can often
create a job at a company because most
employees just do the bare minimum they
just do enough not to get fired because
they don't like their job they're doing
the thing they don't want to do and so
if you show up and show that
determination and drive you'll get
opportunities what else
Alexa what would you suggest to someone
who wants to become an entrepreneur that
doesn't have a lot of confidence so a
couple things that come to mind the
first is the confidence comes from from
doing the work so confidence in front of
the camera for example for me it comes
from having been in front of the camera
lots and lots and lots of times so it's
not that I'm just instantly confident in
front of the camera I've had to do this
right I have 6,000 videos on my channel
you get used to it
and so that once you once you tackle
something difficult to do it again is
not as difficult and they do it again is
not as difficult I had somebody come to
my studio yesterday uh to film for the
first time and so she's being a guest on
my channel and she was really nervous
you know she was scared and she did a
good job and if she comes back and does
it again and does it for her own channel
she'll get better every single time and
so the confidence I don't think is just
ingrained is not just there you build it
by doing the work and then that being
said I think having having a routine
having something that sets you up for
confidence so my office here right like
these people behind me you know I look
at Konya on the back wall that's from a
clip in an interview that he did where
he was saying the time is now that the
time is now to be the greatest you he
doesn't want to want to work in some
giant corporation for the next 30 years
the time is now to go off into the thing
and so being around confident people or
reading a book that makes you confident
or watching a video that makes you
confident can give you a momentary burst
and sometimes that's all you need like
sometimes all you need is that little
moment of boldness that if you feel it
you're able to say yes to that one thing
and you do it and then that helps build
the longer-term confidence and so I
wouldn't think that just because you're
not super confident right now that you
can't be a great entrepreneur I wouldn't
wait 30 years to develop the confidence
so that you can go and launch your
business I just try to find a way to get
started try to find some small way to
get started in every step you take that
stretches your comfort zone right every
time you stretch your comfort zone the
things that are inside the comfort zone
you become more more confident in right
breathing walking drinking water you
know like you're confident in doing that
you've done it so many times and so then
it's just expanding to the things that
you're not familiar with that you're not
successful at yet and starting to build
the skills and competencies next costiy
cost ISIL eov did a super job for two
bucks
Thank You kasi we're gonna go to get a
tea after this happen how should I be
start investing uh very carefully I
think just like anything else I think
like get into a business you don't want
to just go all-in I think you really
really really need to do your research I
think most investors if you're looking
at stock market
most people don't beat the market most
mutual funds if you invest into a mutual
fund as an example these are funds that
are run by professionals most of them
don't beat the market after they take of
their management fees so you're better
off just investing in two index funds
you'll you'll make more money than
giving it to a professional which sounds
so crazy because in most industries
you'd think that the experts do a better
job know what they're doing can give you
the tips and advice but in the investing
world it's really based off of fear for
a lot of people you're afraid you don't
know what to do you don't know where to
put your money and so here's this person
who talks a great game and because you
don't have confidence in it because you
don't know anything about the markets or
how it works then you give them their
money and you end up losing money
compared to what the market is doing and
so if you want to make this your career
if you want to be the next Warren
Buffett like if you really want to
understand invest in and go all-in on it
then then invest little bits then go
mentor and learned and read every book
Warren Buffett's ever written watch the
videos go internet these companies soak
up information and be a sponge before
you start spending lots of money because
the last thing I want you to do is take
out a huge loan or go try to raise a
fund from friends and family blow money
on some deal and it doesn't work out if
your goal is just I'm gonan I'm a
beginner I wanna I want to have a nest
egg I want this extra money they have to
be able to build and grow but I'm I want
to do something else
I want to have a job or want to have my
own company I don't want to be the next
Warren Buffett I'm gonna be the Warren
Buffett of of my industry then just buy
index funds buy index funds it's the
easiest way to get the return on your
investment next Salima how many hours do
you work every day how do you avoid
distraction
two different questions how many hours
do I work a day really depends I don't
really track it I don't what is a
typical day look like for me so
yesterday was a crazy day but I woke up
I was at my studio by 8:30
we filmed from 8:30 until when did I
leave just before 5:00
either filming or just meeting feigns
pretty much straight like one bathroom
break I'm just eating eating bars and
drinking coffee that was a crazy day
most days aren't as like that right like
today I have water I've got some almonds
in there guys soak your almonds 24 hours
overnight it's awesome but I don't like
it doesn't really matter I don't think
what my work schedule is is more
figuring out what it looks like for you
and so I don't I don't keep track like I
need to work 50 hours a week 60 hours a
week 80 hours a week I couldn't sleep
last night right so I there's a great
example last night I couldn't sleep I
got back from my studio I had an awesome
day filming meeting fans was amazing I
went to bed usually go to bed I start
winding down at 10:00 and usually by
11:00 we're asleep so we have like kind
of ritual routine me and my wife to
start shutting out distraction shutting
out phones all that stuff and by 11:00
we're asleep
I couldn't sleep last night so I got up
and what did i do I worked like I don't
know what do you do when you wake up
when you can't sleep I work right my
default is to work if I have extra time
Nina's out with family or friends or
something that I'm not invited I work I
like working like I don't I don't think
of it as whoa as work I don't think of
it oh I'm putting in extra hours I need
to track it I worked so I worked until
2:30 this morning doing some stuff for
trying to dance salsa launched a new
class dunes with Facebook stuff doing
stuff from my new book catching up with
my team again because yesterday I missed
out a lot of stuff because I was just
filming all day so I worked I loved it
and I wanted better at 2:30 and then
woke up and started doing this yeah so I
don't know I don't really track it but
my my schedule
don't go by my schedule like do the
thing that you want to do in terms of
avoiding distractions it's just a
decision you have to decide you treat
people how they should treat you right
like you teach them you teach people how
they should treat you so as an example
phone like I have this this is not a
cell phone there's no cell number I
haven't had a cell number in in a decade
I don't have a phone like you can't
reach me there's no phone there's no
phone here it goes right to a voicemail
I don't want people interrupting me and
I've chosen to make that happen in my
life and so if you really need to reach
me like how does the question comes up
always is okay well what if it's an
emergency what if it's an emergency
right there are so few actual
emergencies first off I try to run a no
crisis business I try to empower my team
to make decisions and if they make a
mistake then it's my fault right but I
miss out on small potential wins like
media I can't hit the media all the time
because they want a response by the end
of the day and I haven't seen that email
you know I don't have a time where I
check email I'm not being pulled into
social media constantly right I checked
my social media in the morning when I'm
on the bike usually mornings I go to the
bike 30 minutes on the bike I'm checking
my social media apart from that I'm not
on it I don't have set times for emails
Facebook is the fastest way to reach me
for my my my team in my my wife but they
also know like Evans busy you know don't
interrupt with things that don't matter
and it's just you setting boundaries you
know alex is here he's working on
something else I was getting ready for
this and responding to someone in my
mastermind group he comes in as a guy
when you have a second like no I need to
finish this right like you have to say
no and later I'll make time for it to
help whatever question he has and and it
has to be important like he's not just
gonna come and bring something super
random to me but you need to figure out
the life that you want to build and then
teach the people around you to respect
boundaries the problem is you are not
respecting your own boundaries and
you're letting people walk all over you
whether that's in person
phone calls social media email right I
used to pry myself as being the guy who
would respond to email super quick like
within 2 minutes you send me an email
boom you get a response but I realized I
was doing a whole bunch of little work
just responding to other people's
emergencies other people's domains for
my time and never actually planning
anything I would never be able to make
videos for you guys I'd never be able to
do this I'd never bill to write a book
if all I did was respond to other
people's emerg uses and demands for my
time so you just have to decide and then
teach people how to treat you there's
some super chats coming in thank you for
the love guys yawn hey Evan how can I
build a community for my website it's a
blog about IT security
I started it two months ago so first off
it's figuring out what is it that you're
bringing it's different what are you
staying for what's the value
you know people come yes for knowledge
but if you want people to stick if
you're talking about a community then
it's around the shared value so a
challenge in this kind of industry is if
it's an if it's if it's just strictly
how to you know how to do this how to
solve this network security issue then
people will come get the answer and
bounce why do they they don't want to be
a part of a community what are they
going to stay because you haven't sold
them on the community they're not
feeling the shared values why do people
why do you hang around the friends you
do why do you go to the groups that you
do yes there's some skills involved but
it's usually around shared values and so
what is the shared value that you're
trying to spread you know for me it's
believed I wrote a book about it your
one word you can go check it out
people feel believe in every video that
I make and not everybody agrees with it
not everybody likes it a lot of people
will watch my videos and say this is
this is stupid believe is stupid
I don't like this I don't like Kevin I'm
leaving right great
like I don't want those people my
community either the people are just
gonna leave troll hater comments I don't
want them a part of my community either
so it's a win-win for everybody
so what is so different about your
community why am I gonna care right the
message has to be clear the message has
to resonate so that if you saw this
because you don't have to have a massive
community yet but if you came across a
brand new IT community what would they
need to stand for what would their
mission need to be for you to be
interested in it because you got to get
those early pioneers the later people
are easier as you're bringing more value
more content but a lot of people want to
just be evolved of it because say yeah
that needs to exist I would love to be
part of a community like that so that's
the question that you need to solve
create something that people actually
care about and it's two months in great
but you could have done a lot in those
two months and it's not so much about
the design and making it look amazing
it's that when I come to your page I
want to feel something and it could be a
blank page with a paragraph this is a
great example if you look at my home
page I threw on my entire website I read
is on my home page myself I'm not a
graphic designer I did it myself and at
the start it was just one page I'm
talking about my mission to solve what I
believe to be the world's biggest
problem untapped human potential and I
don't have all the answers I don't know
how to I don't know how to solve all the
problems and I'm I say on there join me
here's what I'm trying to do join me you
have a skill you have a talent join me I
wanna I want you to be part of my team I
want us to do things together whether
that's working together whether is
partnering whether that's just an
affiliation whatever you're trying to
sell that problem to let me know it's
around the shared value of solving that
problem of untapped human potential and
some people love that and lots of people
have written in and say I do this I do
this I do this I want to join you here's
what I want to do and other people will
bounce immediately and so the same thing
you just do it you create a web you
create a website that when I hit that
page I need to be moved if I'm an IT
security what do I care about from the
values perspective that matches yours
what's the positive impact you're trying
to make and make me feel something and
don't worry about the perfect video or
the perfect graphic design or the
perfect layout or the
SEO someone hits that page it could just
be a paragraph of text maybe your
picture there tell me why it matters
good luck man what else another super
chat you guys are going crazy and the
super chats here one one for G mo what
is the best way to contact you your team
I've tried five mediums with no response
but take a look do a video in edy millet
fastest growing well you just connected
here you know
persistence pays off when you're when
you're reaching out so a couple things
one is persistence one is just keep
trying pay attention to where people are
the most actively responding to things
so this is a great example right being
able to ask a question on an ama where
I'm doing it you're more likely to get
my attention you did a super chat it's
this big green thing I see in my screen
so I'm more likely to see it
I'm also personally much more involved
on snapchat Twitter and Instagram
because I can make a video response
YouTube comments I don't like as much
because I can't make it it seems crazy
but it's it's YouTube it's a video
platform
I can't reply to you personally with a
video so you can't on Twitter on
snapchat Instagram so I do that on my
bike I don't remember seeing you show up
in any of those feeds man I don't
remember seeing you ask me a question on
Twitter Instagram or snapchat and so you
continue to reach out but you also be
have to be strategic about the platform
to reach out to people on that being
said if you've seen any of my content
you would know that in terms of making
requests it goes through the request
line I don't make the decision based off
of one person saying hey do a request in
this person we have a request line go
there cast your vote and the more people
agree with you whoever this Edie
mallette guy is right the more people
agree with you we're more likely to do
that video and so instead of rallying
here to me rally your friends to go to
that video a thumbs up your posts on
Edie and if we got enough people will
take a look there has to be enough good
content on him too
that's a process and I've said that over
and over and over again and tons of
videos but how to make requests what
else okay
we're out of super chats back to the
regular ATS
so tag me more likely to see it Aisha
Evan what to do of my parents are
against my dreams and not letting me
follow them so one of the most common
rules that come up over and over and
over again that I covered in the new
book is not listening to the little man
you know you have people in your life
we're gonna hate on what you do we don't
believe in you
parents are mixed bag a lot of times
what parents tell you to do is actually
out of love they just see success is
different than you maybe they're a
doctor and they see for you to be
successful you should be a doctor too
that's the safe thing it's a strategic
thing it's a smart thing but it's not
what you see it's not success for you
so first is just understanding they're
not trying to hurt you
they're trying to help you just the way
they do it is not actually helping you
right but it's usually at least a
parents out of love not all in all cases
but it usually is a couple things
so first is having an honest
conversation instead of fighting instead
of saying well I want to do this you
don't support me and buppa buppa having
an honest conversation telling them how
you actually feel about this
trying not to put blame on them but
asking for their support and showing
that you understand that it's out of
love for you that they're doing this can
really help make a connection to find
some small way to get started and test
it a great example I think of as Michael
Dell who wanted to start Dell computers
he wanted to start his own computer
business and his parents sent him to he
was in med school and he said you know
why give me one semester I'm gonna take
one semester off or my summer off and
I'm gonna work on my business and if I
can make it go then I'm gonna keep doing
it if not I'll go back to med school
it's a lot it's a lot easier to get the
buy-in for a small thing and then expand
from there
and then three if that doesn't work out
at some point at some point in your life
you need to decide are you gonna live
your life or your parents version of
your life that doesn't mean you need to
shut your parents out from your life
that doesn't mean you need to you know
completely eliminate them or have a
terrible relationship with them but at
what age do you say I'm gonna run my
life like are you gonna wait till you're
30 you're gonna wait to the 40 when
you're 50 are you still gonna just do
things because your parents want you to
and fat ass forwarding for me fast
forwarding helps whenever I'm afraid to
do something I look at myself being 90
100 110 200 you know looking back on my
life at this moment I say if I don't do
this I'm gonna regret it forever so that
gives me the courage to go forward and
do the thing that I'm afraid of so
thinking about you when are you gonna
stop living according to your parents
wishes now you know if you're 8 years
old you may not have much of a choice
right but if you're 16 or 18 or 20 or 25
like how long are you gonna wait how
long you live doing exactly what they
want to do and that goes for everybody
in your life like how long you gonna
live according to what your friends want
you to do or your teachers or the you
know your community at some point you
have to say I'm taking charge of my life
and that comes with consequences too
right that may mean maybe you get kicked
out of the house maybe they don't want
to talk to you for the next year I don't
want to celebrate your birthday's you
know like that may not be that constant
may not be that big a consequence but it
also means that maybe they don't they
don't support you financially with now
your new path you have to be okay with
that
like now you've accepted responsibility
for your life and you've got to make
stuff happen if you're gonna accept
payments from them and they're gonna pay
for your school and they're gonna give
you room and shelter then you can't
complain so you've got to decide when is
it time for you to live your version of
your life okay let's see you next
Jordan Redick Evan you made
a lot of videos on Jeff Bezos now that
he was the richest human being to ever
exist more than any Pharaoh king or oil
tycoon I love that I wonder I wonder if
that's historically correct how do we
correct this and break up Amazon I don't
know I don't care I don't know why you
want to know opinion on that chart your
trade Evan aside from posting more
frequently consistently high quality
content what are some other tips to grow
a YouTube subscribers mic aside from
doing the most important things what are
some tips so I was just having a
conversation today with an entrepreneur
who was trying to get her videos going
and she's saying okay I got to get more
distribution I have to get more people
on my email list I'm gonna promote it to
that video I'm gonna drive more traffic
and awareness and I'm gonna you know
create a campaign to let people know I
always default to the content like maybe
your video just isn't that good right
like maybe people don't like that
even this this video okay look at this
video this AMA series that I do never
does as well as my other videos people
don't want to hear from me as much as
they want to hear from Steve Jobs if I
make a video just like this it won't do
as well as doing a profile of Steve Jobs
I'm not good enough yet and that's okay
I understand that's why my views are on
this video where they are and I want to
keep doing it because the people who
show up I want to help you guys I wanna
be able to answer questions like I wish
I had this opportunity when I was
getting started my entrepreneurial
career to go off and ask questions to
people and so the default should always
be how do I make my quality better
YouTube is distribution if you're making
really amazing quality content it goes
the number one source of traffic is
related videos it's not search we've
stopped even trying to SEO our titles
because YouTube search is not where
people are coming from it's coming from
related video suggested videos because
you have a really good base of content
that people want to see
so the question I be asking myself is
and I
you if you had a hundred views on your
video we had a hundred people watch your
video and I don't know how many people
are watching yourself but you have a
hundred you have a thousand how many of
those people shared your video because
it was really good people would share it
and so what you think is quality content
probably isn't and that's a crappy truth
to embrace and still where I'm at now I
think once a quarter I always I always
go through the crisis of how do we get
more distribution how do we get more
promotion should I should I tweet up my
videos more should it be part of
Facebook groups and get people to know
about it more the end of the day though
it always comes back to you got to make
better stuff yes you have to be
consistent yes you can algorithm hack a
little bit but the number one thing is
you have to make better stuff and you
deserve to be where you are I deserve to
be at a million which is good and it's
bad like I've put in a lot of work I
deserve to have a million subscribers
for all the work I put in and I don't
deserve to have ten million because I'm
not good enough because the content
isn't being shared enough you guys don't
like it enough and some of you are
hardcore and sharing everything and it
means so much and I love it
and a lot of people write in the
comments this this a lot of people write
in the comments this video deserves more
views and attention no it doesn't it's
not good enough I need to make it better
if it deserved more views and attention
they would get it because people would
share it you need to be so good that
people can't help but take notice that's
the game that we are all fighting and so
I almost I don't even want to address
the other things make better content
you're the problem you're the problem
I'm the problem
make better content next Lin Evan I'm
feeling stuck I feel the circle of
people I was in and on helping me grow
but I'm struggling to connect with new
people what are your tips so first off
negative people in your life you need to
remove or limit exposure to it's part of
life and it kind of sucks you know if
you think about how many friends for the
older folk watching you know I'm I'm
Hold'em
I'm 37 at 10:38 in May a lot of our high
school friends are not friends anymore
and a lot of times it can be hard to
really relate to them especially if
you're on a growth path and they're kind
of stuck where they are we lose a lot of
friends as we grow up and and that's
okay
and especially there's people who are
telling you you can't do things or they
make you feel less than yourself and
they hold you back and they tell you
your dreams can come true
eliminate those people as much as
possible now to a previous point that
maybe is your mom right it might be your
mom might be your grandfather it might
be your your Uncle Joe like it could be
somebody in your family which may be
hard to totally eliminate from your life
because now you have two competing
values of I love my family and I iris I
believe in family and I also believe in
standing up for myself and not accepting
crap and so these two values are
competing against each other and so I
would just try to limit my exposure try
to try to spend just the correct amount
of time but you feel okay with and try
not to talk about the things that you
know we're gonna trigger you if they're
upset about your career just try not to
talk about your career and that sucks
for someone in your family but sometimes
necessary to kind of maintain that
balance once you've eliminated a
negative people then you need to invite
positive people into your life the
people that support you on your journey
and if you're not finding those people
you know are you doing the work are you
doing outreach are you trying to be
involved are you active in communities
like this you know I love our community
I look at the comments on YouTube and
people say don't look at the comments
and the comments are almost always
amazing we have a few haters and trolls
like everybody else but the comments are
awesome and if you were in the comments
and responding to people and giving them
encouragement and love and and support
not everybody's going to respond to you
but a good chunk of people will and
they'll check you out and now you have
this online buddy to help you with what
you're doing you could do it in person
I'd be looking at need of events and
conferences and events
that are happening in my local city look
at yesterday yesterday is a great
example so I was filming all day
yesterday right I put up a Facebook
thing on my page 8:30 to 3 o'clock
didn't know how long I'd go like
everybody who wants to come say hi take
pictures maybe answer maybe ask me a
question come on out and people drove
from all different parts of the city and
in the United States to came up to say
hi which was awesome for me but for them
they're connecting with me and they're
connecting with each other so for all
the people who came out in Toronto and
every time I do this in different cities
the people in Atlanta that we did it
with and the people with LA that we did
it with you're connecting people who are
like-minded you're connecting with
people who are fans of the channel
you're connected people who want to be
entrepreneurs you're connecting people
who like the message of believe like
their positive uplifting people and now
you have somebody local in your city
that you've made a new connection with
that if you have problems or questions
you have people to be around and so I'd
be trying to get involved in those kinds
of things and it doesn't have to be in a
big city not everybody lives in a big
city like Toronto or Dallas or Atlanta
but even in your own city look for
events that are happening that are
interesting for you and go to them so
lots of people did not come
lots of people in Toronto asked or
asking the same question as you and did
not come last there yesterday to my
event it's free like just show up and
say hi right meet some people a lot of
the best conversations happened outside
the studio while I was filming just
amongst themselves this is whole group
of people they're talking they're taking
selfies with each other they're
exchanging phone numbers because they
had a great conversation and they had
never met each other before that day and
so if you're trying to invite these
positive people into your life I would
be looking at well how much of your
schedule how much of your actions on a
weekly basis actually lead you to
meeting new people and inviting them
into your life how much time you spend
in online communities how much time
you're spending in the offline event
sort of happen in your city to actually
go off and meet new people
because I think you can and and I know
it's scary I know you know we're afraid
and meeting new people especially as an
adult can be can be tough but once you
get out there and start doing it it's
actually not so bad and you'll meet some
awesome new
potential friends that can help you
weathers build your build your career
just have somebody that you can call on
I think it's worth it
next another super chat you guys are I
love you and you're super chance
positive moment how do you stay
motivated through the whole year so a
couple things here I get asked I get
asked very issue this questions a lot
people asked if I'm on drugs or how am I
so happy every day and if you follow me
on Instagram or snapchat I post
throughout the day most of the time um
couple things one I genuinely enjoy what
I do I like what I do right I like being
here with you like this video
strategically hurts my channel because I
won't perform as well as the other ones
but I do it because I love it I love I
love being able to answer your questions
I'm humbled and honored that you would
want to ask me a question and that I can
help you along your path meeting people
yesterday was awesome like it took away
from my time to film we were we we went
to the end of filming but I I loved
meeting people and so not every day is
amazing and again I was up till 2:30 so
my my train of thoughts might not be
100% right now and I've got a full day
of interviews after this all the way
through but I just I love it like this
gives me energy I love doing this stuff
and so when you hate the stuff that
you're working on on a daily basis it's
hard to stay motivated you can only do
something you hate for so long before
you just want to quit and give up and do
something else and again not every day
is amazing as an entrepreneur there's a
lot of crap that you have to deal with
but overall I genuinely love the work
that I do and I think you need to find
that and spend as much time doing the
thing that you love as possible and
maybe that starts as a side hustle and
you're working towards it and that's
fine but if you want to stay motivated
it's really hard if you only have a goal
but you don't like the process you're
not gonna stay motivated if your goal
like I'm gonna make a million dollars
and I'll do anything it takes to get
there
you won't you'll quit like the goal
itself is helpful but you have to enjoy
the process if you are not enjoying the
process you won't win the people
behind me on my wall the people in the
book anybody who look up to his head
who's at the top of their game yes
they're chasing down goals I want to hit
my next 10 million on YouTube but they
enjoy the process you have to enjoy the
actual work so that's one the second
part is I think when you understand your
one word when you understand who you are
as a human being
it gives you a lot more confidence and
it allows you to design an environment
in habits that support you because I
don't wake up every day super energized
and motivated I'm excited if I think
about it by the work that I'm gonna do
today but I don't wake up and jump out
of bed and like I'm fired up ready to go
and these like this it's extra hard when
when you're low on sleep it's harder to
get up and do everything so having an
environment right like I walk in I might
be tired and I got Steve Jobs looking at
my face and I got Howard Schultz and my
parents and and these people having
habits and morning routines really helps
and so what I would be thinking about is
you have been motivated at some point in
your life you have been extremely
motivated there's been moments in your
life where you have just really crushed
it what I would try to figure out is
what led to you being motivated like
that were you watching a video reading a
book having a conversation what was it
what were you doing doing yoga
meditating like drinking water whatever
the thing is I don't care what was the
thing that led you to feel motivated and
then put that daily like start your day
with that if watching the video gets you
feeling motivated and fired up then you
wake up and you put on a video do that
every day right and I think that
combination really helps one feeling
like the work you're doing matters and
you enjoy the process for me getting up
and and working till 2:30 in the morning
was fun
like I enjoyed doing the work that I was
doing I wanted to sleep but I enjoy
doing the work and then to having that
that thing that you designed into your
morning routine like I read a page from
this book every day that's why I wrote
the book is because I wanted I'm using
it and I wanted you guys to see if if it
worked for you as well I wake up the
first thing I do is I go to the bathroom
I pick up the book and every
to pay to the book and what it does is
I'm getting to genius ideas from Steve
Jobs or Oprah Winfrey or whoever and it
just makes me start to think bigger
makes me start to realize that I want to
have a big impact like these people and
then I write down my three goals for the
day I stick it on the back of my phone
and that's how I start my day pretty
much every day and so that works for me
it may not work for you but the good
news is you already know what works for
you because you have been motivated but
you're just not making it a consistent
habit you wake up like it's an accident
put it into your morning routine and you
have more success just be more divot
what else we got more super chats super
chats are done okay back to the axe uh
what do we got
Jackie Raymond Evan what would you focus
on in your LinkedIn profile your side
hustle or your day job I think it just
depends on what your what message you're
trying to get out I think LinkedIn is
usually more a workplace thing or b2b
thing if you're selling to if you're
selling to businesses then LinkedIn
could be really helpful if you're
selling ticket to a consumer brand if
you're selling you know fidgets spinners
to the consumers it it's not gonna
really matter what's on your LinkedIn
profile and I think it also you have to
factor in how much your current boss
cares about your LinkedIn profile will
it cost you your job will it cost you
awkward conversations you know if you're
working at a company and it says on your
LinkedIn profile that you really have
your own business and that's your
ambition some bosses are super
supportive of that I had a great
conversation with Stephen Kelly from
sage we did a live hangout like this and
he said we love it when our employees
are doing their own side hustle because
it helps them understand entrepreneurs
better that's who our customers are and
we support that I don't know that most
companies are that progressive though I
think if a lot of people saw that you
were doing something on the side your
boss or your boss's boss or your boss's
boss's boss and people who may not have
the direct the direct connection to you
might feel that that is inappropriate
I might doubt
or commitment to the company and so I
think that could potentially be a career
killer so you just have to understand
the psychology in your organization does
it impact your job and then does it
actually help you with your side hustle
if you're not selling b2b then it won't
do much for you
if you are selling the businesses then
there's possibility good luck
yan another super chat another super
chat from yan Thank You Jana getting two
teas from Yan what's my favorite book
and why will you come to Germany my
favorite book my favorite books are the
ones that I wrote I think you have to
love the stuff that you do besides that
not right I know I you know I let me
dive quickly on that I'm not trying to
promote what I'm doing I think you
really need to create for yourself I
think you really need to use the
products that you're making so I make
the YouTube videos for myself right like
I view every video and I learn something
from them if I don't learn something
from them I don't post them and so the
guy has to pass the evan filter and my
team's got a pretty good Evan Evan
filter now they know what I like and
what I don't like but that message I
believe it has to be positive there has
to be some inspiration to it is I've got
to learn something from it it's not just
somebody hating on somebody else you
know in the example we had a post we had
a clip this week we're featuring
somebody and ain't it in the clip he
gave some advice and then in the same in
the next sentence he was derogatory
towards women and like I'm not posting
that it might have been great advice but
but I'm not gonna post something where
he is attacking and it's not just women
if you're attacking anybody you're
attacking a religion you're attacking a
culture you're attacking anybody I just
don't want them on my channel i I
understand that's what they're thinking
and maybe it was a joke or maybe it was
serious but I don't want that on my
channel so I told my team we're not
gonna post that and we need to find a
new a new rule number eight cuz rule
number eight is no good in my books and
so for both of my books I wrote them for
myself
I wrote I never wanted threat atop time
I was a success book I think well we
have the videos why would need a book I
was toying with the idea of that one
page a day in the morning and I tested
it with myself and like I like this like
this is work and this is actually pretty
cool and then that's when I decided to
make the book for you guys too and so I
think you have to love the products you
create and you have to use the products
you create
if I'm picking a book that is not my
book one probably the most influential
one is the 4-hour workweek not because
of the idea of working four hours a week
because if you look at Tim Ferriss he
doesn't work for hours a week but the
idea of delegating was super important
because when I was going when I was
reading that I was doing way too much
myself and the idea that you need to
really prioritize your time back to an
earlier question we had around how do I
avoid distractions um some of that came
from from the 4-hour workweek the idea
of not responding to every single email
like it's an emergency
not not building my identity and pride
of myself as being the guy who responds
really quickly but instead being the guy
who is going off and solving big
problems that switch really helped me
and so it's probably a bit dated there
are other versions of it updated
versions of it but that book had the
biggest impact on me thank you for the
super chat yawn oh another super chat
you guys are you guys are giving me some
lots of tea I like it
PU Sh hey Evan what do you think of
Amway so Amway again just to my last
point you want to make sure that you are
using it anyway if you look at any kind
of network marketing as a general
concept it's it can be awesome but it's
just a business model there's nothing
inherently wrong with it as a business
model the problem is people get into it
thinking that they can just make a lot
of money and like any business if you
try to get into it just to make a lot of
money you're gonna fail you have to
actually like the thing right and so a
challenge with Amway is a lot of people
who are in the program don't actually
use the products that they're selling
they don't actually care about it
they're just seeing people as an
opportunity right there they're seeing
their friends or they're knocking on
doors and you see that person is my next
vacation that person is my next suit
that person is my next pair of shoes
right and that's the wrong way to look
at it you have to have a personal
connection to the things that you're
selling and I mean Emily sells tons of
products but if there's some that you're
not using don't sell those and if
somebody asks you hey I'm way selling
this what
think that you know what I love my
products if that's true for you but I
don't use that one so I can't give my
endorsement I've it apart from I like
the company right and that honesty
really helps and so if you want to
succeed in Amway first is looking at
during any network marketing first is
looking at your upline you want to make
sure you're getting training the people
who've done it they're training you the
giving you knowledge and experience
you're not just on your own doing your
thing and one of the biggest letdowns
for most network marketers is that their
upline sucks their training sucks they
don't have real mentorship they get into
it thinking they can make a quick buck
and nobody's actually teaching them what
they need to do to be successful so
that's one and then to have a tight
personal connection to the products that
you're selling so I would not sell you
this book and talk about it if I was not
proud of it if I'm not using it myself
right I would not recommend this other
book if I wasn't using it right even for
companies who approached me like sage
with Stephen Kelly are you sage are you
sage in my business I like it as an
accounting program we can open up your
sage and I can look at your accounts
with you and I can navigate my way
through it because I actually use the
product right and I think that's where
most people step down and so I'd be
looking at what are the products that I
really like from my if any and if not
then jump and go somewhere else what if
I can connect with and then what are the
products I'm comfortable recommending to
my mom like that's the filter I would
recommend these books to my mom would
you recommend what you're selling it I'm
Way to your mom and if it's yes and
awesome build a story around that and it
would snow then then stop and find
products that you can't as a business
model apart from that it's it's great
like you get training from people above
you you don't have to worry about
fulfillment you don't have to worry
about coming up with new products
yourself all you're doing is building
connections and building relationships
and so if you love doing that it's a
great potential business model when
everything works out a lot of times it
doesn't work out and so you have to
figure out if it's the right fit for you
thank you for the question thank you for
the super Chad preesh I hope that helped
all right back to the normal ones
Johanne hello Evan if you will be asked
to choose one would you rather be
flexible or adaptive hello believe
nation be a blessing would I rather be
flexible or adaptive would I rather be I
see them as the same thing flexible or
adaptive I don't know I see them as
pretty close so I'm not giving you much
help on that one
next a cash Evan I see a big business
opportunity from from climate change I'm
still in school any advice for me any
advice for me from you how long will it
take to completely save Earth from
climate change Wow
so first off I love it I wish again I
had somebody to connect with when I was
in school and that's these kinds of
questions too
I don't know enough about climate change
to really answer that question what I
know is there's gonna be smart people
like you who will figure it out it's
part of what I want to try to do you
know I think I think the person who's
gonna solve climate change the biggest
fear I have is instead of going into
science they go into sneakers and they
become a low-level manager at Nike I
never get above them never get above
that level because sneakers is not
really their passion they kind of just
fell into it where they could have
solved climate change and so my thing
around human potential is figuring out
the thing that you could be Michael
Jordan at right you're gonna you have
Michael Jordan level talent and
abilities and capabilities at something
and so it's figuring out what that is
getting the exposure to find that thing
and then going all in on it so if you
love climate change at least love maybe
you don't love climate change if you
love solving climate change that's an
obsession for you that I would encourage
you to get as involved as possible you
know you could be the person who makes a
difference does it take 10 years 20
years 50 years a hundred years are we do
we not solve the problem they have to go
to go to the moon colonize Mars you know
because we've screwed our planet over
those are possibilities and so without
worrying about like the end of the world
thinking okay how are you going to be
part of the solution so maybe we don't
solve climate change but we could if you
get involved and you do it right take
that approach and so instead of thinking
on the macro too much I think what can I
do
solving human potential my big goal I
don't think it ever gets solved they
like it's a lifetime goal that can't be
solved there's always more potential to
a human being but I'm gonna do my best
right it's that idea of you you're on
the water and you're trying to empty the
ocean with a spoon there's the buddha
who said that you wake up and you go to
the the ocean and you're trying to empty
the ocean with a spoon and you can never
do it but every day you make a little
bit more progress towards it and so I
just encouraged you to get as involved
as possible and take it upon yourself
it's your fault if we don't solve
climate change
now go what else do we got
here's some questions
Emperor red panda Russia how can I get
more bamboo leaves I have no idea Salima
thoughts on paint masterminds um depends
on the person what I would suggest is
for masterminds you try to understand
the person leading it as much as
possible if it were me looking at
somebody's master mind I would try to
find content about them I would try to
follow them on YouTube on Twitter
snapchat Instagram where they're hanging
out and see how much of their message
resonates with you so I have a I have
two master minds I have a offline one
here in Toronto that we meet once a
month and I have a kind of undercover
online one that I don't really talk too
much about mostly because if it gets too
big then my time is kind of split
between two many places but we have a
Facebook group and every every week
somebody else is asking a question and
you get answers and so once a month at
least you're getting your question
answered to help you grow so how would
people find that mastermind group well
it's on my second channel I have a few
videos talking about it and the people
who join they like me
right like I'm in it I'm given advice if
you like what I'm putting out if you
like videos like this if you like being
a part of my community then maybe this
mastermind is a good fit for you if you
don't like my stuff or you don't know
who I am then don't join right and I
think whoever it is that you're looking
up to for the mastermind group there's
so much content on people just see do
you resonate with them do you feel their
vibe do you think that they can help you
and look them up mister your research
you could try to talk to people who've
been involved in the groups but for me
it's more just do I get a good vibe with
this person or not so I don't know that
I've been a part of a paid mastermind
but for me time is money too
right so I mean I YouTube mastermind
every week I meet with Tim Schmoyer set
it up and there's a couple other YouTube
creators we're all at various sizes with
our channels but YouTube is a full-time
Plus income for everybody in the group
and we meet once a week and we talk
about it talk everybody takes turns
sharing what they're doing and so that's
a half hour commitment for me once a
week I don't pay to be part of that
group but but the time you know the time
showing up half an hour every week
that's a good chunk of time that's on
usually my YouTube day so that's half an
hour less of research for you guys and
then ongoing of kind of communication
and supporting people I'd like to make
sure I'm providing as much value as
possible so that's what I would do
really do your audit really do your
homework to figure out do you like the
leader of this group does their message
resonate with you do you want to be more
part of it next up Michael Evan how do I
get video seen I'm new to social media
and find most of my content doesn't get
put in front of people like on Facebook
the only show it to eight out of my 7k
people yeah so I answered this question
a little bit to chart your trade earlier
make better content that's how the
algorithm works man that's how Facebook
Gallagher in the works and YouTube's
they never show your content to
everybody unless it's really really good
stuff so make content that people will
have to share
it's not a distribution problem it's not
Facebook's problem it's your content you
have to make it better that's it
Diane please share your group Evan I'd
love to join thank you what do you think
of Peter Shankman so if you check out my
live channel if you go to this channels
home page is a link on the side to my
live channel in some of the descriptions
there there's a link to join that
Facebook group that mastermind group I
didn't intend for this to be a promo
session for that and again I also don't
want too many people because I want to
do other stuff too it takes it takes it
takes time and I love it but it also
takes time from other things so anyway
you can check that out Peter Shankman I
don't know who Peter Shankman is I feel
like I should know who Peter Shankman is
the name sounds familiar but it's not
ringing a bell at the moment so maybe
it's just cuz I'm tired
Joanne hello Evan how are you I'm good
you weren't able to answer my question
but that's okay I'm chatting again just
want to wish you a blessed productive
day thank you
yes flexible versus adaptive I don't I
still have an answer for that I don't
really understand it but yes thank you
for the love and I hope you have a
productive day as well what else what
else what else what else what else what
else
I'm looking at the chat Moo nice hi Evan
I'm late I wanted to ask a very
important question a very good business
model for a polling app and I think it's
amazing use their faces on paper the
whole logic is ready maybe having
patented but I'm scared but I'm scared
as people out there might steal it I
have to get it developed cheaply I'm
scared to move ahead what can I do
please up so you know if you have a
patent that's your protection against
the IP but a software patent doesn't
mean anything to be honest like there's
so many ways around the software patent
around an app patent that it's almost
meaningless you just have to play the
scenario out like the honest answer is
you just have to go ahead and make it
because because what what else what's
your alternative
first off like somebody else has your
idea - somebody else has bowling ideas
is lots of polling apps that are that
are out but also new polling apps that
are coming out that will look similar to
what you're doing the answer is you just
need to keep going and get better right
if you look at snapchat and Instagram
right snapchat had all these great story
ideas and Instagram said we're losing so
we're gonna we're gonna copy snapchat
story ideas and then sat chat starts
losing right Instagram stories are
blowing up I don't know how many guys
around snapchat Instagram stories but
they just stole that idea now they
didn't they didn't steal it like they're
not gonna go to jail for it the if there
was any kind of patent on it it doesn't
cover it because software patents don't
mean anything so the only way through is
to just make it better like snapchat
needs to come up with better features
you need to create the best polling app
and then you need to keep making it
better and people will rip off your idea
and you need to just keep making it
better people rip off my videos all the
time I need you just keep making it
better that's the game but you don't win
by sitting on your couch and not doing
anything because you're afraid and
that's that's the harsh truth but a lot
of people never get where they want to
go because they're sitting on an idea
because they're trying to figure out the
perfect execution because they're
worried that somebody's gonna take their
idea and run with it instead of them and
then it's five years later and you still
haven't done anything with it and then
you watch somebody else make tons of
money off your idea and so I don't want
that to be you people will steal your
idea you just need to stay ahead of them
you just got to do it better
constantly and that's why the passion is
so important because if you just see it
as an opportunity people who have the
passion will crush you but if you love
this thing and this thing has to exist
and it has to be better then you'll keep
making it better and you'll stay ahead
of the game each time guys it's been an
hour it's been awesome thank you so much
for the love I always love coming and do
these doing these for you I'm gonna I'm
gonna try to keep that commitment to
keeping it going on Thursdays I know I
didn't get to all the questions so
hopefully next time next week I'll see
you back I'm going to pop into a whole
bunch of different interviews and
hangouts now on
my channel and others I hope whatever
you're doing it's massively productive
it's noon here for me whatever time it
is for you unless you're going to bed
there's still time before you go to bed
like there's still time to make today
matter there's still time
to make this day count I try to approach
every day that I want to make something
that my grandkids are gonna be proud of
I want my grandkids to watch this video
and the interviews I do today I want my
grandkids to watch those too I hope that
whatever you do today and whatever time
was remaining even though it's only 20
minutes before you go to bed make
something that your grandkids will be
proud of
happy Thursday guys I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is much
love I'll see you soon